good morning and it's nice to be back at
simon's in person after a lot of virtual
events here so i'll be talking about
learning restricted boltzmann machines
and this is based on joint work with guy
bressler and freddie poehler
so my main interest in this talk will be
understanding the algorithmic aspects of
learning graphical models with latent
variables
but first i want to tell you about
what's known about learning graphical
models without latent variables and even
though i'm sure all of you know
graphical models please bear with me
let's make sure we're on the same page
in terms of notation
so graphical models are a rich model for
defining high dimensional distributions
and the important thing is you know when
you define them you specify their
dependent structure
so you know a canonical example of this
that's going to recur throughout this
talk is an easying model
which gives us a way to define the
distribution on plus minus 1 to the n
which looks as follows so we have
variables capital x1 through xn
and the probability of them taking on
some realization little x
is proportional to the exponential of
some quadratic plus some linear function
so let's dig into this a little bit
so in fact what we define is an n by n
interaction matrix j
that describes for each pair of
variables i and j
whether they want to be the same or
different signs and that comes out
through whether the entry in this
interaction matrix is positive or
negative
and the same way we have this notion of
an external field which is in the
absence of interactions we can think
about this vector little h as
representing all of the individual
biases so the variables are not uniform
over plus minus one but they might have
some bias that depends on the strength
and size of this external field
now in order for this to be a
distribution that needs to be normalized
so the usual notation is that you know z
is the normalizing consonant it's called
the partition function
and of course this is really just the
tip of the iceberg so you know much
beyond easing models you can talk about
models over larger alphabets that takes
you to things like the pots model
you can also talk about models in which
you have higher order interactions
instead of just pairwise interactions
we'll talk more about that later but
roughly you can think about replacing
what's happening in the exponent instead
with a higher degree polynomial so that
way you might have three y's or even
higher order interactions and of course
you could make it directed in which case
you know you could talk about things
like bayesian networks
now the important thing is that
underneath this probability distribution
is a graph and that this graph captures
the conditional independent structure so
the usual thing that we do is we take
our distribution and we define a graph
on variables x1 through xn
and then we add edges for every pair of
variables for which the corresponding
entry in the interaction matrix is
non-zero so if these two variables have
some sort of affinity or they want to
agree or there's some sort of
disagreement
and the important thing is that all of
these familiar notions of graph
theoretic notions of separation
turn into notions of conditional
independence of the associated
distribution
so for example if you have a pair of
nodes i and j
and you have a subset u
well if you have the graph theoretic
property that all paths from i to j pass
through the set u so u is a separator
for i and j
then it means that if you condition on
all of the realizations of variables in
x u that you get that i and j are
conditionally independent
yes
is this always the case or do you have
to make an assumption about the
distribution being yeah so that's a
great question so this isn't an if and
only
what's true is that regardless of the
way that i set the actual non-zero
entries this conditional independence
property will be true but i could have
conditional independence properties
where i have a conditional independence
that's you know is not actually a
separator in the graph theoretic sense
yeah that's right so you need strictly
positive and you know we'll we'll need
that condition but thank you
so you know the main question that i
want to start off with before we get to
the main topic of today
is you know what about the algorithmic
question about learning graphical models
from samples
so what i'll mean by learning graphical
models here is that you're going to
assume some kind of upper and lower
bounds
on the interaction matrix and the
external fields but subject to those
constraints what you want to do is you
want to learn the underlying graph
theoretic structure
so this you know line of work goes way
back so it starts off with the work of
chao and liu who gave a polytime
algorithm for learning graphical models
provided that the underlying graph is a
tree
there's a much more recent work of
karger and stein where they gave a
polynomial time algorithm that works on
graphs of bounded tree with
now one of my favorite works in this
sequence is this work of guy bressler
which was a very surprising result to me
and to a few other folks because what he
did was he gave a polytime algorithm for
learning graphs of bounded degree
so if the graph has degree at most d
then it gives an f of d times poly and n
time algorithm now the f of d in front
has a doubly exponential dependence on
the degree
but what's really surprising about these
results is that you can learn graphical
models
for which you can't actually sample from
them if you had them so he was actually
learning it in a regime where the
sampling and inference problems were
known to be computationally hard
and these were improved in a sequence of
works with vufreidal and clivens and
mecca where they improved the dependence
on the degree where the f d just became
singularly exponential in d and this is
optimum
and of course there are other threads of
work on you know algorithms for learning
graphical models
where the name of the game is you make
some sort of stronger assumptions
they're usually assumptions that imply
as a consequence
things like the fact that your
underlying graphical model does not have
long-range correlations and those cases
sometimes you can get better algorithms
maybe even things which are poly and d
and poly and n
so my main goal today will be to try and
understand what can we say
algorithmically
about learning graphical models
but with latent variables
and so the main question is really you
know
the motivation for wanted why you want
to try and solve these kinds of things
is that once you allow
latent variables it allows much more
interesting phenomena because among the
variables that you're observing they can
influence each other through unobserved
mechanisms
so it's you know very scientifically
important for example because if you
have a bunch of observed data maybe if i
can find a parsimonious latent variable
model that fits the data very well that
gives me some evidence that maybe this
is a good scientific theory
so let me tell you about one particular
latent variable model that's you know
one of the simplest in this area
which is called the restricted boltzmann
machine it's something that was
popularized by hinton in the 80s and 90s
and basically what you do is you take an
easing model but it works on a bipartite
graph and one of the two sides in the
bipartition is unobserved
so i have observed variables x1 through
xn
and i have latent variables y1 through
ym
and they're going to produce a joint
distribution on plus minus 1 to the n
cross plus minus 1 to the m
and the way that it works is that the
observed variables only interact with
the latent variables and vice versa they
still have the same types of external
fields but this in turn is itself an
easing model
which describes this joint distribution
on x and y
but now the challenge is even if this
underlying easing model is bound to
degree
what happens if we don't observe all of
the latent variables so what happens if
in this bipartite easing model there's
an entire part in the partition that we
don't see
how much does this confounding mess up
our algorithms
so restricted boltzmann machines are
very important in machine learning they
have tons of applications and things
like feature extraction collaborative
filtering
actually one of their claims to fame is
that there were a building block of very
early versions of deep learning because
what you would do is you would take
these restricted boltzmann machines and
you would stack them on top of each
other as a way to create hierarchically
more complicated probabilistic models
but the main question which i'm going to
be interested in is are there efficient
algorithms for learning restricted
boltzmann machines
and there's going to be one key
challenge which is really going to
stymie our attempts yep
so what exactly do you mean by learning
things do you know
existence
variables or do you want to that's a
great question because you know learning
the latent variables is going to be
tricky because there are multiple latent
variable models that are consistent with
the data for now what i'll talk about is
learning a description of the
distribution on the observed nodes but
even then you can ask for the proper
learning problem of can i go back and
find an rbm that actually fits the data
even though you cannot uniquely
determine what is the rbm that generated
your data so that's a great question
so in any case let me tell you about the
main technical challenge there's a very
simple thing to wrap your head around
which is that you can take this nice
restricted boltzmann machine
and once you marginalize out a single
node the trouble is that you end up with
higher order dependencies
so what happens if i take an easing
model defined on this star graph right
and i take the node in the middle and i
marginalize it out
the trouble is that the corresponding
induced distribution on these three
leaves
is no longer described by pairwise
interactions because it's no longer an
easing model it has a higher order
interaction
so in fact what type of distribution do
we get when we take these simple easing
models and we marginalize out nodes
we get something which i'll get into
which is called a markov random field so
in particular we'll be interested in
binary markov random fields and a binary
markov random field of order r
is just the distribution on plus minus
one to the n
which has the same type of functional
form that we've been talking about so
far
but with the twist that this function
that goes in the exponent is now a
degree at most our polynomial
and the classic folklore fact is that if
you take a restricted boltzmann machine
where all of the latent nodes the ones
that you're not going to be observing if
they have degree at most are
when you marginalize all of them out
what you will get is a distribution on
the observed nodes that is itself a
binary markov random field of order at
most r
so that's the classic fact
and one of the first questions we could
ask is you know okay so maybe i can
learn restricted boltzmann machines just
by treating them as mark of random
fields and learning them that way
now i'll warn you that there's going to
be a big catch to doing that but let's
dig into you know what exactly is known
about efficient algorithms for learning
markov random fields
so there's a work of clybuns and mecca
and hamilton at all
where they gave an algorithm
which runs an end to the order r time
for learning markov random fields of
order r
provided that
the variables have bounded degree
unfortunately you know there's a bit of
a computational problem here which is
that end of the r really is tight so
under standard hardness assumptions you
actually can't do better
the best running time for learning an
order r markup random field really is
going to require n to the omega r time
and this is based on something called
the sparse parity with noise hypothesis
just that learning a tea sparse parity
with noise which is one of the basic
problems in computational learning
theory requires end of the omega t time
and so the idea is roughly that you know
order r markov random fields are rich
enough that they can capture things like
sparse parity with noise even worse they
can capture them with bounded degree
mark of random fields too
so let me try and refine the question
that i care about
or uh for this for this or for learning
is it the same method being used for
both
well you know one of the things that you
can ask for learning for an order r
markov random field is you can ask can i
learn another markov random field that
produces a distribution that's close on
tv for example
but actually a lot of these things work
with even weaker notions of learning
namely improper learning that it's hard
even to learn a description of the
underlying distribution that's close in
tv
so i'll not
more refined available is can we do
better than end of the day time so can
we hope for algorithms that you know
like in the case without latent
variables they run an f of d times poly
and end time that's the goal that's our
goal
it's the design these type of fpt types
of algorithms
and you know end of the day time is
actually kind of trivial for reasons
that i'll get into later because it
corresponds to type of brute force
search which is really that sort of
naive baseline
so let me tell you about our results
before i'll roll up my sleeves and we'll
get into some of the technical ideas
so first let's talk about the
representational power of restricted
boltzmann machines
so one direction i told you was folklore
that if you take
you know a restricted boltzmann machine
with bounded degree
and you marginalize out these unobserved
nodes you end up with a markov random
field but actually the pretty surprising
thing is that the converse is true too
that if you take any markov random field
you can actually realize it as a bounded
degree restricted boltzmann machine so
the theorem is that every binary markov
random field f of order t
can actually be realized as the
distribution on the observed nodes
of some restricted boltzmann machine
where the maximum degree of any hidden
node is at most t
so this is actually a complete model for
this class of markov random fields so
this gives in in a sense a very precise
characterization of the representational
power of these bounded degree rbms
and in contrast you know the things that
were known before really required much
larger degree so for example there was a
work of martins at all where they showed
that rbms can be really rich they can
represent things like parodies or more
generally predicates that only depend on
the number of ones
but the catch was that the degree was
actually linear in the number of
variables which doesn't really tell you
anything about the hardness of learning
rbms with bounded degree
but you know once we have this
equivalence between markov random fields
and rbms
we get a lot of striking results about
the hardness of improper learning as a
quarreler
so for example under the sparse parity
with noise assumption
it turns out that then it's hard to
learn
any representation on the distribution
of the distribution on the observed
nodes that say close and total variation
distance one third in time better than n
to the order d
and here it's even a very weak notion of
learning you can even do it improperly
where you just allow your algorithm to
spit out any unnormalized function that
can be computed efficiently this problem
is still hard
in fact you know things get even worse
because not only does our reduction you
know
from from mrfs to rbms produce bounded
degree but if you start off with a
markov random field that represents the
sparse parity of noise
you create an rbm that not only has
bounded degree but it has a bounded
number of hidden notes
so it turns out that learning an rbm
even in this weak notion of improper
learning is hard for constant degree
with a constant number of hidden nodes
so that's thinks
and you know in comparison a lot of the
earlier works they required a huge
number of latent variables things where
the number of latent variables was
linear or even larger than the number of
observed nodes
but maybe you know the better question
since i'm more of an algorithms person
is all right so maybe we were too
optimistic we can't really hope to learn
you know rbms without any assumptions
but you know are there still some sort
of well-motivated and natural families
of rbms where we can do much better than
end of the day
and the answer is yes it turns out that
if they're ferromagnetic namely if the
interaction matrix and
this vector of external fields are
non-negative then we'll be able to give
exactly these kind of strong algorithmic
results
so there's a long history of study of
ferromagneticity it plays a key role in
you know classical statistical physics
theoretical computer science
and you know these types of models then
have applications to things like um you
know
the spread of
innovation on social networks is one
place they've used i'll skip this but
you can ask me afterwards but let me
tell you about the main results which i
want to get to so our main result is
that there's a simple greedy algorithm
which runs an f of b times poly and n
time with sample complexity f of d times
log n
which learns ferromagnetic rbms
but again you need these upper and lower
bounds on the interaction strength to do
so
in particular what does learning it mean
so we output a description of the joint
distribution on the observed nodes as a
markov random field so there's a fairly
strong notion of learning in fact what's
neat is under this notion of learning
well you can actually use the model that
you've learned on the observed nodes for
downstream tasks like performing
inference
for example you can use these models to
give a ptas for estimating the
likelihood of particular outputs of your
model
so i won't say any more about that but
really what i want to get into is you
know some of the ideas about
how exactly these ferromagnetic rbms are
so much easier than the general case of
rbms
and i'll also add that everything that
i'm going to say is actually going to
generalize to ferromagnetic easing
models provided that you have bounds on
how far apart your latent nodes are from
each other
okay so let me roll up my sleeves and
tell you about a really cool technical
connection that you know was definitely
news to me
so you know the way that we're going to
give a simple greedy algorithm for
learning these ferromagnetic rbms is
through analyzing the properties of this
particular function which is called the
discrete influence function
so the way that it works is that you
know we have some sort of graphical
model
and we can think about pinning some
variables in the set s to being plus one
for the value
and we can look at when we pin those
variables to plus one
what the resulting expected you know
what the bias is of the corresponding
variable x i
so the way to think about this function
is that it takes subsets
these subsets are subsets of n minus i
and it asks if i pin all of the
variables in that set to plus one what's
the resulting induced bias
so it's a function from subsets to a
real value
and it turns out that this function has
some pretty magical properties that you
know are amazing
it's actually submodular
and even more amazingly you know the
properties that under light
submodularity have actually been studied
for a very long time in mathematical
physics but without explicitly making
this connection to submodularity
so the main theorem which you know we're
going to reason about is i claim
that if we fix a ferromagnetic easing
model
then for every node i this discrete
influence function that i described
above
is a monotone function it only increases
in value when you fix more and more of
the nodes and it's also submodular in
the sense that it has these rules of
diminishing return
and it turns out that submodularity has
really been studied in disguise since
about the same time that it was
introduced into discrete math but it's
been studied in mathematical physics but
it usually goes under the name of the
concavity of magnetization
and it's really in modern terms it's
related to what's called the
multi-linear extension
so let me tell you some beautiful and
intuitive properties
about these easing models particularly
ferromagnetic easing models
now the original reason they were
introduced in physics was as a way to
model macroscopic properties of
materials
you do things like understand phase
transitions
how the external field affects whether
or not magneticity you know emerges as a
global property of your material but you
model that material just with these
simple pairwise interactions between
each of the individual particles
now the thing that you might care about
if you care about the physics
applications are things like the average
magnetization so you can take your
easing model you can look at the
expectation of the sum of all of the
spins and you can divide by n
and you know let's assume that this
interaction matrix is non-negative so
that it's a ferromagnetic model let's
assume that the external field is the
same value h everywhere and that h is
non-negative
then there's some really intuitive and
classic results that go back to the 70s
you know one of them is that if i take
something like the average magnetization
and i increase h by a small amount the
external field what should happen to the
average magnetization it should only go
up
so this is really a statement about the
partial derivative
of the average magnetization as a
function of the external field it's
non-negative
but in fact there's a more remarkable
property which is going to be the key to
our algorithm
is that magnetization should also have
this law of diminishing returns
if you think about starting from two
external fields h1 and h2 and h2 is much
larger than h1 well if you increase h1 a
little bit you look at the change in the
average magnetization and increase h2 by
the same amount well since h2 was bigger
to start off with you should increase
the average magnetization less
so that law of diminishing returns is
captured by the second order partial
derivatives of this average
magnetization
which is why it's called the concavity
of magnetization in mathematical physics
is because the average magnetization is
actually a concave function
and it's related to things like the
griffiths her sherman inequality which
captures exactly this notion of
diminishing returns it'll turn out that
mathematical physicists were studying
this property in the 1970s discrete
mathematicians were studying
submodularity in the 1970s but they
actually talk about the same thing when
it comes to ferromagnetic easing models
oh can i ask a question here yeah so the
uh
the
external bias this uh h that's constant
for all of the
yes
um
okay great so but it's not a
vector yet it's not a vector yet but it
turns out that um based on a method that
you know the actual ghs inequality
we'll actually be able to see this as
one consequence of ghs and submodularity
will be another consequence where it's
like partial hi partial h
we're getting great that's exactly right
but we're getting
uh great
so let's try and dig into it now let's
take some modularity for granted and let
me convince you that there's a simple
algorithm for learning this
ferromagnetic rbms because it'll just
come from assembling a lot of simple
observations
so you know at the end of the day the
thing that i care about is learning
ferromagnetic rbms which have latent
variables right i talked about the
discrete influence function of uh you
know a ferromagnetic easing model but
you know if you have this discrete
influence function for a ferromagnetic
easing model is submodular then so too
is the corresponding influence function
when i look at something with latent
variables because what i'm doing is i'm
taking this nice monotone submodular
function
and i'm just restricting what kinds of
subsets you're allowed to plug into the
function because you can only pin the
observed nodes
but now this discrete influence function
inherits all of the nice properties of
the function that i had before so that's
great
now here's the key idea and this is the
thing that you know i'll reason about
with a picture for you
is that this discrete influence function
the reason it's going to help us learn
ferromagnetic rbms
is because what i claim is that the
maximizers of the discrete influence
function are nice
and reveal important properties about
the graph theoretic structure
see what i claim is that they ought to
be the two hop neighbors of some node
so if we think about our rbm
and we think about some node i and i
care about its bias
well if i can only talk about pinning
any of the observed nodes the question
is what observed node should i pin to
have the most influence
on the underlying bias of this node
and the answer would be all of the nodes
that are distance two away from i
because once you condition on these
nodes and you pin them to plus one
then all of the other observed nodes are
conditionally independent so they no
longer have any other influence
on the bias of i
so that's the key point is that if we
can actually find the maximizers of this
monotone submodular function then what
we should have is we should have an idea
about who are the two hop neighbors of
this node on
so the two hop neighbors exactly because
they act as separators
so the formal statement is that you know
if we have these sort of alpha beta
non-degeneracy conditions
namely we have lower bounds on the
strength of any non-zero interaction and
we have upper bounds on you know that
essentially control how biased
individual nodes can be
then the quantitative statements and i
should mention that you need some
conditions like this
to make the graph theoretic structure
even for an easing model identifiable
but in that case you know the thing that
you can prove to make some of this
intuition precise
is that if i take the discrete influence
function for some node i
and i look at a subset s that does not
contain all of the two hop neighbors of
i
then i can do better
i can make the discrete influence
function larger by some quantitative
amount that depends on these
non-degeneracy parameters
so that's the key point
and now we're in good shape because you
know the main question is how can we try
and maximize this discrete influence
function
well actually also since the 70s you
know we've studied things like uh you
know maximizing a monotone submodular
function subject to a cardinality
constraint on the set that we plug in
and there's this classic work of
namehauser at all where they give a one
minus one over e approximation
now that's not quite good enough for us
but actually their analysis tells you
something a little bit stronger than
that because it's a simple greedy
algorithm that keeps picking a new
variable to add into my set that makes
the most progress on my function but it
turns out that you can actually use
their analysis and turn it into instead
of by criteria approximation algorithm
namely it's going to achieve an
approximation factor that converges to
one but at the cost of looking at larger
sets
that you know expand the cardinality of
the thing you're competing with
and now what you can do to turn this
back into this algorithm for learning
ferromagnetic rbms is you take your
discrete influence function just
restricted to the observed nodes you
start from some node i and you keep
greedily adding other observed nodes
that increase the discrete influence
function
and eventually what you're going to do
is you're going to luna superset
of the two hop neighbors why because if
you haven't learned a superset of all
the two hop neighbors there's another
node that should make a lot of progress
and then it violates your approximation
algorithm constraint
so that sounds like we're almost done
because instead of learning the two hop
neighbors we've learned a superset of
the two hop neighbors
but then we can use a lot of standard
techniques just to prune that down
because we've reduced down to a constant
size sub-problem
so once we have monotonicity and
submodularity the problem is easy we get
our efficient algorithms
but now let's talk about you know why
these things are actually submodular and
this part is you know
pretty mysterious
so you know actually i have to work with
something a little bit different than
the discrete influence function there's
another nice thing you can do which is
you can look at something that's called
the smooth influence function instead
where the idea is that instead what
you're going to do
is this influence function looks at the
expected bias but what you do is you
change the external field
h so in particular you can recover the
values of the discrete influence
function
because if i think about you know how to
mimic the effect of pinning all the
variables in s to the value plus one
i can accomplish that just by taking the
external field and setting the external
field for all of the nodes in s to plus
infinity because that pins them to the
value plus one
so this is just the continuous extension
of the discrete influence function but
it'll be easier to work with things like
the partial derivatives of this
influence function even though it
contains all of the old information
and you know in retrospect this is
really in the in the language of
submodular functions this is what's
called the multi-linear extension
so you know i i probably should show you
what the griffiths first sherman
inequality is it's this monstrosity
right here
does anyone have any intuition for this
not freddie freddie might
no
okay well you know clearly you can see
that this implies the property we wanted
so we're done
actually i don't have very much
intuition for this but it's used you
know this technique it's um there's a
very important technique called the
random current method which is used to
prove it but the important thing is
really that
it's related to proving these bounds on
the partial derivatives that i talked
about earlier
so in particular the ghs inequality can
be used to prove this fact that i gave
you before about the concavity of
magnetization
in fact it can prove another related
statement which is if you look at the
partial derivatives of the smooth
influence function
but where you vary the external field at
j and k
then that has the same type of law of
diminishing returns where the second
order partial derivative is non-positive
so that's the important thing
in fact there are other related
inequalities you know in mathematical
physics things like if you look at the
covariance between two different nodes
well since it's fair magnetic you sort
of expect that these should be
non-negative
and you know this is related to some of
these other properties like showing that
that the smooth influence function its
partial derivatives are all uh
non-negative
but now we're in good shape because
we're going to take these things which
are corollaries of the ghs inequality
for granted the statements about these
partial derivatives and we're going to
prove submodularity and then we'll be
done
so how do these properties about the
partial derivatives of
you know the influence functions imply
that you know in particular the discrete
influence function is monotone and
submodular
and essentially the proof is by
integrating
so let's do it in the simpler case we
just want to prove that this discrete
influence function i defined earlier in
the talk is monotone as a function of
the set s that we're pinning to the
value plus one
and the idea is that um you know let's
take some external field h
and let's add in
something to make all of the
corresponding external fields the set s
be pinned to to plus infinity so they
get into plus one
and then the idea is that we can look at
what happens to the influence function
when we add in the set the variable j
into the set s and compare it to what
happened before so here what we're
looking at is how much does adding in
the variable j and pinning it also to be
plus one affect the bias on the node i
so in particular you know we can turn
this into just um you know the integral
of this partial derivative
because what we're in effect doing by
adding this node j into the set s
is we're just pinning its external field
to be plus infinity
so we can think about this as really
just integrating all of these little
changes in the external field when we
increase it all the way to infinity so
that it also becomes a pinned variable
in that case we're in good shape because
we know from this griffith's inequality
that all of the terms inside the
integral are non-negative
so in particular it implies that the
difference between these two
these two discrete influence functions
is also non-negative
and that gives us the monotonicity
property right that pinning more nodes
only positively affects the bias of any
other node at least if you're in the
ferromagnetic setting
and the proof for submodularity is
basically the same type of argument you
fix two different sets s and t
you can talk about you know these
modified external fields where i pin
everything in s to plus infinity i pin
everything in t to plus infinity but
what i want to do is i want to prove
some type of law of diminishing returns
so i ask you know how does the discrete
influence function change when i add j
into the set i can write it out as the
same type of integral
but now the key point is that i can
lower bound it instead by changing the
external field from h prime where s is
pinned to h double prime where this
larger set t is pinned
and the reason i can go from one to the
other
is because actually
you know the the second order partial
derivatives are all non-positive so as i
change everything inside the integral
i'm only going to decrease it
but now we're in good shape because the
right hand side is literally the
difference
between the discrete influence function
i add j in to the set t and i leave it
out so this proves exactly this law of
diminishing returns that you know is
related to things like the concavity of
magnetization
so let me quickly give you a summary and
then i guess it's lunchtime
but uh you know the main things that i
wanted to get across is that there are
some very interesting questions even if
you take
some of the classic problems about you
know whether you can learn graphical
models and you ask the same type of
algorithmic questions but with the twist
about what happens if there are latent
variables instead
that can make the problem much more
computationally difficult a lot of
things which you know we we know and
love in the case without latent
variables
like learning graphical models with
bounded degree that stuff does not carry
over to the case where you have latent
variables because then you get much
worse hardness results things that tell
you you need end of the day time
and the way that we proved this was
through this precise characterization
of the types of distributions that can
be represented as bounded degree
restricted boltzmann machines
that gave us you know these lower
balance not only for learning bounded
degree restricted boltzmann machines but
even with a constant number of latent
variables
but that doesn't mean that the game is
over because there still can be very
rich models of rbms which we can beat
these type of end of the d bounds and i
gave you a simple greedy algorithm based
on submodularity and the concavity of
magnetization
for learning ferromagnetic rbms
but i think this is very much a story
that's still to be written i think you
know one of the main open questions is
really to identify other tractable
classes of latent variable models where
you can beat these types of end of the d
guarantees
so i'll stop there and you know a few
minutes for any questions you might have
but thanks for your attention
yeah thanks for the talk um i was
wondering if you could comment at all on
the relationship between the approach
you're taking and the kind of
there's like the statistical literature
on learning markov random fields
a lot of that um
has kind of historically focused on
continuous random variables like
gaussian or gaussian populace kind of
thing but there's also versions of it
that
are in your kind of more binary space
the important difference is that often
there the focus has been on
using the pairwise markov property or
exploiting the pairwise markov property
to learn the structure of an mrf so
where you have like x1 and x2 and you
condition on all other variables in the
in the set
and i guess i mean there's like
statistical issues with that but like
complexity-wise how does that relate to
what yeah what you're talking about
that's a great question so for example
you know there are some really beautiful
works about taking let's say gaussian
graphical models and marginalizing out
some of the nodes and then asking
whether you can you know find some sort
of parsimonious explanation maybe in
terms of the precision matrix being
sparse right
now those all rely on the property that
if you marginalize out nodes in a
gaussian graphical model you get back a
gauss
so the big issue is that for things like
these easy models as soon as i
marginalize out i create a higher order
dependence
so that property of you know having only
pairwise interactions be preserved under
taking marginalization
seems to be a very specialized problem
yeah but it doesn't i mean i agree with
what you just said but there's also
uh
procedures that allow for general markov
random fields so like look at cliques in
the way that so in this literature it's
in terms of like clique potentials
instead of pairwise interactions but
still the pairwise markov property holds
even in a higher order mrf if two
variables are not adjacent then they're
independent conditional on this one set
which is the set of everything else yeah
yep but there for example you know one
of the big questions is also what
happens with the computational
complexity of those types of things
because we define it with clique
potential so sparse party with noise is
a very very simple markov random field
with very small order too because it
just depends on the sparsity t
so one of the big issues is that you
know sparse party with noise is hard
that imposes some pretty strong lower
bounds on the computational complexity
of things even if you can represent them
in terms of clique potentials
but maybe there could be cases where you
could get around that i don't know
these influence functions that you have
here they're defined in terms of these
expectations
and i think i i think if i'm following
right these expectations you're able to
approximate because they're the samples
that you
yeah
so
what's kind of like an intuition on
well this function is sub sub modular
but i only see it with s
samples and i have to sort of com
combine
many uh um
different uh uh
like greedy out
algorithms what's sort of the intuition
for how to piece this all uh to
heather
yeah that's a great question so you know
the important thing is that once you
know the hard part for things like
markov random fields is figuring out
which other nodes
are in your potential like in your
hyperedge so the important thing is you
know the what the way that we're
learning it is we're learning a markov
random field on the observed nodes
but once we've you know done these
greedy algorithms around each node we've
drastically pruned down which are the
other nodes that could participate
so then there are a lot of other
standard techniques you can do once
you're you know down to a much more
constant size problem
but you know it's it's not so clear that
we have the right way of combining all
of those things there definitely could
be more clever ways too
well so you know even so here it's um
it's a maximization problem which is
cardinality constraint because
you know you wouldn't want to put the
entire subset in there for example but
you know one of the issues is that if
you're trying to maximize a cardinality
constrained monotone function
and it's not submodular then it's very
difficult to say something non-trivial
so if you think about for example the
rbms that come out of the sparse parity
with noise type of reduction
they'll have this property that you know
there are a few other nodes
that once you find them you can affect
the bias of this node that you care
about
but until you find all of those other
companions you don't have any effect on
the bias
so one of the big issues is that without
some kind of
property that prevents you from making
all of your progress
in one last step
it's very hard to know how you're going
to make progress towards maximizing
whatever you know influence function
care
character
so it's not necessary for this algorithm
to work but it's also not so clear
what's another way to articulate some
interesting class of models that evades
what goes wrong with the sparse party
with noise examples where everything
happens at the end then you end up with
a brute force search to figure out what
are the companion nodes
so if i understand your results
correctly you're essentially trying to
do proper learning of an mrip for the
marginal can you say anything about
what's happening in the lincoln space
that's a great question say one of
another interesting open question is
whether or not you can actually learn
a ferromagnetic rbm and actually find a
ferromagnetic representation
so here you can go the other direction
once you have the markov random field
you can translate that to a bounded
degree rbm
but it won't be ferromagnetic anymore
so in fact when you think about this is
the part that i sort of glossed over but
you know one of the reasons people care
about ferromagneticity is it actually
enables things like efficient sampling
for example for the jrm sinclair result
so in fact there are a lot of things
that you can do with the ferromagnetic
representation if you can learn it but
we learned something that's not
necessarily ferromagnetic as an rbm
but still we can use these things that
are called li yang properties because it
inherits a lot of the nice properties
about the partition function so we can
still do other things like be able to
efficiently perform inference but
sampling would be an open question
i think all remaining questions should
uh pass through
so thanks a lot
okay